[Music]
jake your body's kicking and skin
as clear as a summer day a summer day in
what part of the world
this could be an insult if we're talking
summer in northern greenland in which
case skin is clear as a summer day means
your face is bright red and the tip of
your nose is black and will pop off from
frostbite
the cake hasn't arrived yet nathan woke
up with a chicken pox so you don't have
a ring bearer
reverse zoom i'm sorry i'm just so bored
by yet another sitcom wedding that i'm
just shouting out strange camera
movements
look what i found on my veil wait why
are we moving on from this hairball
sneezed out of a rodent's ass why show
it around to people like it's this
casual discovery we need to know if the
solution to cleaning that thing is dish
soap and a spatula or a trash can and a
blow torch
why is anyone calm yeah he should be
cuter his face is too small for his head
i just remembered a quote from my
martial arts instructor if size mattered
then the elephant would be king of the
jungle it has nothing to do with what's
happening in the show right now but
they're making fun of a kid's face so i
had to take a mental break to try to
continue to like these two
seems like people are pairing off for
adventures and we have the best report
and this seems like one of those moments
where comedy writers don't have anything
funny to say so they just have a
character state the obvious but when we
do it it's super meta
flat top and the freak we always deliver
show refuses to give us a flat top in
the freak episode what's that
seriously well then show refuses to give
us a flat top in the freak spin-off and
six picture movie deal am i safe now
it's gonna be a perfect day phone call
for you sir ah thank you
being interrupted by a tragedy moments
after stating the day will be perfect
cliche
that would be the cake guy saying he has
arrived but why would the cake guy call
the rec center and not call jake
directly on his cell jake should be
suspicious of this call before he ever
lifts the receiver to his ear
your ex-boyfriend is here on our wedding
day why this is my crew
well what a coincidence you called me
boring so i
leveled up my cool and now i run the
bomb squad leveling up your cool to try
to attract someone who dumped you
it's gonna take hours so you should
probably just cancel the wedding you
could just un-cancel it shortly after i
hear stuff doesn't stay canceled all
that long around this time in the
nine-nine
oh is it somewhere between zero and two
how fascinating what are the rules about
appropriate fingernail length for
detectives i mean sure i'm probably
supposed to be interested in diaz's
dating distaste but i can't stop
thinking about all the ways these long
nails would be a nuisance in a job like
this
i just got an email from the mayor's
office telling me if i'm the next
commissioner of the nybd
because a b plot wouldn't even be a b
plot if its plot didn't conveniently
begin a round the same time as the a
plot found its first lull in the story
that's right
b plots only exist because of a-holes
well amy in this life it's sometimes the
unlikeliest outcomes
it feels like you're winding up to
propose again here i was good catching
amy
would you no bill did it
why is this so heavy because you made
them do an all-frosting interior if your
cake has an all-frosting interior it
ceases to be a cake it is now simply a
frosting also frosting is objectively
the worst part of any wedding cake and
is increasingly taking up more and more
space from the cake itself i get it you
want cool shapes and designs and such
but maybe just mold a sculpture out of
pure fondant for people to look at and
then serve an actual dessert to your
guests instead of fancy play-doh
art okay okay focus up let's do this
start an investigation while off duty
sounds neat i'm just gonna lock that up
in a little box of my brain and never
open it ah the doctor sleep stratagem
pretty sure that only works for gothic
hotel ghost peralta
are you actually mad that someone might
not hate you twitter charles you put
this picture me up on the wall casual
evidence tampering is casual it's almost
like this show is much more concerned
about comedy than actual policing
screw the universe the universe is a
dick that's astronomist
okay you've been staring at your phone
for 45 minutes bathroom breaks in the
year of our lord 2020.
dear greyhound god and hound heaven do
corgis have spines i thought cheddar was
laying facing the cake until my eyes
drifted to his hind legs how can you lay
facing towards and away from something
at the same time
i'm sorry the vent is very tight and no
one on my team can get into it if boyle
is the only one small enough to slide
into the vent to find the bomb
how was the bomb placed in the vent in
the first place cause the bad guy is
girthy my daughter found my hidden room
and discovered some blueprints
a funny callback that really falls apart
when you break it down first there was
no hidden room this obsessive display
was not hidden it is lit with
directional lighting in what could
easily be the living room
second if the daughter called to save
amy jake peralta
why would she ask for jake and not amy
third why call the rec center at all why
not the police station to warn them
about the bomb
fourth why does she have access to or
even want to use dad's burner phone and
voice distorter
and lastly listen how she warns them
it's set to explode at 5 30
everyone inside will die that is the
most menacing way to warn people about a
bomb
and if that kid isn't a real villain in
another episode i'm walking
obviously shopping i'm always heaps
dropping google amazon applesoft
it's wedding time something showrunners
say every sweepsmonth somehow makes it
into the script
friends colleagues gawking new yorkers
and parents peralta said that their dads
got together for drinks and arm
wrestling could they not make it down to
the precinct for their children's
wedding
ex-boyfriend bomb squad guy managed to
sneak in with a robot ring bearer
where is family i was going to do an
adams family themed wrap but my
beatboxer isn't here
don't worry i'm sure it's somewhere in
one of those god-awful hotel
transylvania movies you were in
and yes i know that has nothing to do
with this show but i'm going to take
every opportunity god grants me to send
those regretful pieces
of celluloid that's right the hotel
transylvania movies are so bad they got
sinned in an unrelated property on a
separate channel dedicated solely to
television shows it's actually pretty
impressive now that i think about it
names itv sins take you jake and amy to
having to skip your butt
your butt is the bomb you clearly stole
that from jake that was his joke and you
plagiarized it as i've often said a true
poet writes from the language and
experience of their own heart
not those of others i totally made that
up you don't even have to check
well from the look on my face i'm sure
you can guess what it says no
we have no idea at all just tell us you
monster and this seems like one of those
moments where comedy writers don't have
anything funny to say so they just have
a character state the obvious but also
make it meta
what when we do it it's super double
meta
you're just gonna leave him with a
grenade stuck up his ass yes lana i'm on
a rampage
if you've ever wanted to know what it's
like to probe into the back end of
cinema sins and learn our deepest
darkest secrets behind the sims podcast
is just what you need each week writers
aaron that's me today that's me
and jonathan yep discuss what it takes
to create the content that you enjoy on
youtube
hopefully enjoy they probably do i mean
even if they don't we talk about it
that's true i guess i'll just wrap this
up real quick and let you know that you
can listen to behind the scenes here on
youtube
or search for the show on your favorite
podcast player yep human hair is
indistinguishable from badger fur honey
badge you don't care
jake peralta yes can you bring me my
chapstick
that was not the cake guy here we go
good way to judge a woman have her run
away from me and then run back
all right dario tell lieutenant wells
what you told us killed those three wall
street guys
my life is nothing but a comedy let me
get this straight you think that killing
those guys is funny
i do and i'm tired of pretending it's
not
this cake took us days to do and these
two morons dropped it down the stairs
there's a robot at my wedding beautiful
stephanie
are you guys doing the thing where
someone gets to object to this union or
is that later i'm not doing that
i just want you to be loose okay i'm
loose